how's it going right now we're back
we're playing some speed runner it's
super intense enjoy the video
I guess Davis InDesign yeah how's it
going the wrong way
suck us or [ __ ] dad what you touched oh
now I'm just confused like there's
there's no we're not words flow I guess
you're supposed to run I get it got up I
brackets Cal now I shot myself oh okay I
didn't die why are we go in I know about
if no one I'm going up here guys done am
I tricked you don't nuts on me how bad
you grapple me Collier okay oh ah ah how
do you go check oh no hey guys wait for
me yeah yeah if I could see the level
you guys can you got any yet mints he's
not cool there we go
like I have this superpower stop don't
don't you why do you shoot me you idiot
u mad u mad bro no why would I be mad
I'm so good at this game
oh good what was the point of the
tutorial if they're not gonna [ __ ] I can
ever do the war jobs it's unfair it's on
Tennyson how do you know the world off
blow it oh [ __ ] no it's gonna win come
on we could go on forever literally like
someone job yes I did it themselves one
did I win yeah I'm good at this game we
all just [ __ ] die this is
host cheater
oh just learn how to play noobs l2p
[ __ ] what's the name of us
female Horace I'm swingin save me on
that p8x hey Freddy but no I won are you
talking about
ah don't whine grapple me no one grapple
pants how do you shoot forward
I can only graph a little guy pull
upwards I had a special I am I wasted oh
geez
so you can grapple forward is that it if
you have a special item yeah how do you
know which way to go look at that ah
caramel [ __ ] damn it
oh [ __ ] no I want to come here yes yes
come on don't don't yell at me there I
can every I nail the waters ever mice
know why don't I win oh [ __ ] sorry I
don't get why don't a win they don't
understand what is the game won from me
it wants it as one of us they're outrun
the others so they die crap all that mm
oh hey oh here you go here you go
it's yes for you it's just for you yeah
I always forget the slide not a better
job know what's waiting nobody
yeah what's that cheaters what's up
what's up the bullet jumps coming peace
can you handle the world yeah no yeah
you stress me
oh [ __ ] I got like supersonic grapple
ken why I grapple through you it's not
fair
science doesn't make any sense gosh that
would have been so amazing amazing Oh
God is no one ever didn't see this when
we run into okay makes we got to get ken
this is I'm sorry Ken I don't meet this
one I'll die out oh yeah come on gotta
run gotta
guys wait for me please whoa you're
going through the wall
ya know what is coming out here see wait
I can't do all jumps guys oh I can't
nevermind okay what's happening
okay basic wait from here guys I do
wanna play to screen let them all the
time passing oh [ __ ] on a stick it's so
closer to me wait guys I just want to
play with you come on come on guy can go
can I wait I want Ken shitless go minks
come banks whose minks like I just like
really I got a small discreet
there was one out of three or your
stereo feels good to be the winner well
I gotta win this one so don't even try
to pie nice look at this [ __ ] haha
what's up it's the ultra grapple that's
a grapple
any day son any day I always miss that
[ __ ] all right this guy Ken let's get
can come on come on hey come on I don't
just do something okay I don't care okay
I'm full yet I'm coming for you guys so
fast you like flash on the paths Oh
sneer up look at me go what out come on
yes I was amazing
hey cheater that's what you get how's
that cheating I played by the rules
unless you know
come here minx yeah go go [ __ ] god damn
it I had you items are of the best
I need more items don't pick up that
item minx don't don't you guys yes yes
pink horsey power fabulous fabulous nice
nice I'm actually I'm enjoying this game
it was [ __ ] in the beginning it's
actually pretty damn yes intense anytime
I win I enjoyed the game like it could
be the worst game ever and I hail on the
Pels [ __ ] no don't you dare apple meadow
go go go go minks you have to win he'll
red has a point grapple BBB we all have
one point now that's amazing
I guess bucks hey Thank You box box
oh I slide it [ __ ] yeah
the first time I did this line ever
decided to learn the layout there you
know I I knew before I was born but
whatever how do you do
I stick a shoe are you cheap this is
this is what I do this is my living this
is my town except the [ __ ] wall jumps
jeez oh nice trouble with this how you
don't know I didn't code escape hey you
guys should walk there yeah do that
hahaha I think it's funny I don't know
oh don't box me
don't you dare box me oh you didn't box
hideous love forever I can't commit [ __ ]
Gandalf we'll see you later
hey hey hey please wait I'm ready too
far ahead
minx wait up wait up wait up
ready aim wait up I have a present and
it's called friendship
what's called friendship come on you
watching this right now hate you what
come here minx I have a present [ __ ]
that was actually not good damn you
dodged that [ __ ] what am I doing here
okay grapple versus rockets you go first
copy here
yes God I wanted the item that was a
great reception with it yeah oh you bad
Oh
placing my button so hard
I pressed through my controlling Emma
home box what the hell is that box gonna
get Adams hey Ken what's up no no not a
day not today not today sir
this on ain't no minks gonna win this
[ __ ] okay when I'm fine it'll with
anything no [ __ ] this game your fault
right all right all right
it seems awesome hahaha holy [ __ ] that's
intense
I don't how do I get ahead in the dark
[ __ ] sure on Petes alright for us hope
you enjoyed this first episode of the
speenrunners we have plenty o more and
it gets I think each video gets batters
if you bros are interested in more let
me know they like if you do hit
subscribe to come to birth today after
you in the next one
deborah you brush justin bieber the
original goal was $250,000 and we just
killed it with 400
and it seemed incredible this has been
an amazing experience